a shocking video
showing a brutal beating in the las
vegas las vegas school students laughing
as one of their classmates gets humble
viewer warning here this is a tough one
to
of
watch
the attacker has been charged with
battery it is unclear what injuries the
victim suffered
the school district says it takes every
incident very seriously is committed to
safety and will not tolerate violence in
the classroom sadly school officials all
across the country report higher levels
of violence misbehavior assault
and drug use among students
judge i don't know if you saw these in
the classroom or you saw these in the
courtroom these kind of cases or if you
prosecute these kind of cases but how
should we think about this and what
should they be doing in las vegas school
district and other school districts
across the country
there's only one way to think about that
that's a crime
that's a crime that not only dehumanizes
the victim
but the crime that is being committed in
front of other students with no one
stopping this young woman who's doing
this this defendant at this point
uh is the kind of thing that uh
it has to stop now if there were other
students that were laughing if there
were other students that were involved i
don't know at what point that video
started i don't know you know what
happened before that one of the things
the public always has to be aware of is
that when you get the end piece of a
video you never really know what really
happened but right there that is a beat
down that is an assault they call it
battery in in nevada i called the school
district to the uh uh the police
department and they said that the woman
has been given a citation the student
who was the student who was doing the
beating and that she couldn't give me
more than that because she's a juvenile
okay she's a juvie what i want to know
is what is a juvie record what is the
law in nevada does it allow us to raise
uh to put this young woman this 17 year
old uh to prosecute her as an adult that
is not a girl who for the first time is
hitting another girl she's not just
slapping her she's punching her with
fists she's got a beat down i don't know
what the injury is to that to the victim
there has she got any cerebral injuries
any kind of concussion i don't know what
it is is it is it a simple assault or is
it a felony assault but what this has to
what has to happen is has to stop i want
to know why this teacher is standing
there like you know
is there a guy in the class come over
here and get her off this student you
know it's it's uh it's unacceptable and
this is a reflection of the violence
that is going on around this country
from people getting nuts and roads raid
and road rage to people in dunkin donuts
fighting with each other over masks it's
got to stop and the only way it's going
to stop and i'm talking to jen saki is
if we're soft on crime and there are no
consequences this will continue yeah i
was going to blame saki too
that was my idea no the teacher doesn't
want to get involved because the trial
lawyers will sew her pants off and this
happened to me one time it did yep um i
was sitting behind a kid in junior high
in spanish class and i was just
whipping rubber bands at the back of his
neck like what what what this is the
part about you say we didn't get a
chance to see what was happening and
then so like the back of his neck just
got beat red just really tore his flesh
up and then after the last one maybe the
seventh one
he turns around and he just went woo and
i covered up and i blocked all the shots
but i mean he he definitely
got a few shots off did you get in
trouble
yes and i threatened that we were going
to fight after class and then
immediately we got suspended in school
suspension
and then we patched things up and we
ended up stealing beer from the special
office where they used to entertain for
fundraisers and then stashed it outside
should i interrupt here did we yeah the
statue of limitations passed no no i
think i've told my father about this
um and then went and got the beer later
before a dead show these kinds
that did not help this story what so
well what i'm saying people need to get
involved someone stood up and took the
kid off of me when he started raining
blows down
you you can't have someone just launch
off on some girl like that and not
intervene or maybe you should have been
hitting the guy in the back of the net i
deserved it i totally deserved and maybe
that's what that girl did
police officers law enforcement in
school should we have more of that greg
or
in some schools absolutely but you know
what this this brutal beating reminds
you of prison that's that's a jailhouse
beatdown right you know no one
intervenes because no one wants to get
on the bad side including guards and
inmates and men which is kind of sad so
schools like maybe schools like this are
just holding cells for kids and they'd
never learn anything but how to throw a
good punch because that's i mean
apparently she knows how to throw a good
punch but that's something you learn in
jail you know forget kamala harris the
real reboot has to be about our corrupt
educational systems right we're
producing kids that are learning nothing
but stuff like that you know forget
college they're already in the hole
right they're already in the hole in
high school what do you do
they have school resource officers in
those schools i saw you the other night
on trey gowdy's show you were excellent
talking about esteem and the way we had
to address some of these challenges
there's clearly some mental health
issues maybe here as well how do you
think in terms of like what was the
beginning of the video also go back to
the beginning of their lives right so
somebody who is beating somebody else up
like that might have been beaten up or
something i don't know but also i would
look at the graduation rate at the
school district it it will surprise you
um and i think that for many decades we
will be analyzing the impact of school
lockdowns on these children and on
teachers and what their lives are going
to be like having been massed up or been
in
remote learning however i will say this
there are some school districts where
there are bad problems at school where
there are many parents who want
permanent remote learning so that their
kids don't have to deal with that right
and a lot of it revolves around the
bullying and i hope we're able to
address that as well hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else